[Music]
you have a uh a perfume yeah i think i'd
have a perfume it's available
commercially yes some things have
changed since we last saw each other
yeah you come in with a perfume i've
been wanting to come out with a men's
scent and no one seems to want to market
it
it's
smells like cinnamon and desperation is
mine
this is billionaire boyfriend is your
scent oh yes this is the second one yeah
there's boyfriend and then there's
billionaire boyfriend okay and um it may
interest you to know that they cover two
totally different olfactive categories
it's
i don't know how to you're supposed to
do this and then walk through it right
i'll do it towards the camera
not with your face though why not your
face you never do because it could you
know get in your eyes and your mouth you
want to sort of like spray it and then
walk into it like that you know like
like this
like
i've put a lot of this stuff on yeah
yeah
it's really my i'm gonna come home my
wife's gonna say you're having an affair
wow i really overdid it i apologize i
think it's drifting its way towards the
crowd now and they're starting to pass
out
good lord uh it smells good though
i was like maybe they put water in there
for i don't know no no this is real this
uh this whole set is going to smell like
this for a long time
uh you do really fun ads for for for a
billionaire boyfriend oh thank you yeah
it was fun to make them yeah it was a
fun ad campaign you did one where you
play a bond girl yeah kind of yeah you
sort of you're taking my take right yeah
by the way and i also thought you you
look amazing in this app but let's let's
take a look at that i think it's fun
[Music]
some girls will go to any deaths for
their boyfriend
i have only one
it's like something
i have one criticism
you're going to get a fan correction
about the octopus
that's possibly the worst looking
octopus
i've ever seen the octopus
please get it there he is
the octopus is like that's kate walsh in
a bikini
there there's a lot of struggle that all
i knew is i wanted to wrestle an octopus
i was like i don't know let's make a
perfume where i can wrestle an octopus
so it was it was i just had this how
ridiculous that would look and we
couldn't get the thing to submer it was
bad enough to try to get it through
customs it was like this octopus became
the bane of our existence and in the end
it looked kind of phony that is that one
foot we couldn't sink it we had like
eight people so we have weights put it
[Laughter]
getting killed you are leaving private
practice do you know if they're gonna
what they're gonna do to your character
are they uh are they going to kill off i
don't know i don't know what they're
gonna do but i was like i kind of want
to go out in a blaze of glory like
literally like just just run out of a
building on fire completely and i don't
know something really dramatic you want
something dramatic something hugely
dramatic but i don't know if that's
gonna happen choke on a chicken bone
i don't know while on fire
you're on fire you pause eat a chicken
sandwich
spray the perfume walk through it